[Applause]
my design career and my life and design
really started on the potter's wheel
i'm jonathan atler i am a potter
a designer and author
and lover of glamorous spaces
my expertise in design comes from being
in this business for a long time and
having done it all from being a potter
to making furniture and all the stuff
that surrounds you to designing spaces
from the smallest studio apartment to
the biggest hotels you can imagine and
i'm here to share my years of experience
with you
[Music]
[Applause]
so maybe i'll just
walk you through what i'm doing
so i am going to make a pot
[Music]
and i think it's called throwing because
the first thing you do
is throw the wedge of clay
onto the wheel
and then
the guiding principle
of making pots is control
so when making a pot
i always think
i'm in control of the clay the clay is
not in control of me
so
[Music]
the first thing i'm doing is i'm just
going to center the clay on the wheel
and it always wants to be on center
[Music]
water is my friend but not too much
water
and with potter you kind of need to
make a pot with confidence and speed
and intentionality
so the very first process is to center
the clay
the key
to making a pot is to always have your
arms braced
against your legs so that there's
nowhere for the clay to go and you're in
control
then once the clay is centered
you
make the hole in the clay
[Music]
my main goal in making this pot is to
try not to get clay on my white pants
and
i actually started wearing
white pants because as you can see the
clay that i work with
is actually a very light color it's not
like a red clay and so when it
gets on my clothes it kind of dries and
looks white so i started wearing white
jeans because
they were the only pants i could wear
that i could get dirty
and go from day to evening covered in
clay and people might not notice
if you're working with clay that comes
out of a bag it gets really like
set in its ways and
smacking the clay on the ground like i
did is a great workout and it kind of
seems to shock the clay
into
being more plastic
clay
has a mind of its own
and one of the funny things about clay
is
that even after you finish making a pot
the clay wants to keep spinning
and so
one of the things you'll see me do is as
i try to raise up the walls of the pot
my hands are going
up and i'm kind of squeezing the clay
between my
hand on the inside and the outside
but then i will also
sometimes
do the same motion
but just going in a downward motion
because it helps to untwist the clay and
kind of stop it
from
doing its turn
i'm just gonna make
kind of a very classic and traditional
shape
which is kind of nice and full at the
bottom
it just gets a little bit narrower at
the top
and it's incredibly
relaxing and intuitive
and
inevitable form for a pot
it's funny making a pot is actually the
ultimate expression
of
the apollonian versus the dionysian
because the clay
wants to
explode in chaos and fly off the wheel
and i
need to
be in control
of its impulse towards chaos
it's funny i've had a strange journey
and i would hardly say i'm a carefree
person but i never had a plan at all
i kind of just
made pots
sold pots
and kind of let it all unfold
i'm glad i did it that way
for me
clay was almost like a gateway drug
to
a general interest in design
and to a creative life so
you never know what your interests and
hobbies can lead you to it never crossed
my mind in a million years
that i would grow up and become a potter
and
then a retailer
and a furniture designer and a designer
of
restaurants and houses and hotels
all while still
being a potter first and foremost
so now i've gotten the pot to the
approximate size and shape i want and
i'm going to use a
metal rib
to help define
the shape
and smooth the surface
i will trim away the excess clay at the
bottom
um
no clay on my pants or shoes yet
stay tuned
i should be wearing an apron but i'm not
a voila a pot
i actually need to make this for a
sample so i think i shall
we kind of do these like mugs that have
little like faces on them or these pops
that have faces on them
and so this is going to be like a mug
within that family
i want to just have the
slightest of slight little bell shape so
that
it'll make it a little more appealing to
drink from
and because this is a prototype that's
going to be slipcast
i'm trying to make it approximately
20 bigger than i want the final product
to be
so right now it looks like a giant mug
but the finished mug will probably be
kind of muggy
the mug
maybe i'll just do like kind of a big
kind of
like a flared cylinder
[Music]
i first tried pottery at summer camp
when i was 13
and i kind of thought oh i'll give this
a try and from the split second i
touched clay it was
on and a lifelong love affair with
pottery began and it has been the most
rewarding relationship ever
[Music]
being a potter
was kind of the best
training grounds for being a designer
because
all of the concerns and issues that i
address in all of my design work whether
it is making a pot or making a piece of
furniture or designing a space
are all the same and they can all be
boiled down to the issues in making a
pot it's about proportion
it's about silhouette it's about harmony
it's about balance it's about
finishing something well and not doing
it just halfway
the end result of a pot involves color
and pattern and something as simple as a
mug or vase can involve a bazillion
decisions
that are all pretty much analogous to
the decisions you have to make
when
designing a room or house so everything
i needed to know
i learned on this silly potter's wheel
[Music]
with pottery i discovered something that
i loved
and i kind of just leaned into it and
miraculously it led to a fantastic
creative career
[Music]
trying not to get one speck
of clay on my
self
i think i've got this
even without a little
splatter lit
[Music]
because normally i would have like a
towel over my leg and an apron and
all different levels of protection
[Music]
hey voila
a pot
is done